while some behind-the-scenes
negotiations continue this week on nafta
the heavy hitters have gone home there
appears to be little chance now of
anything substantial happening before an
unofficial deadline set by the u.s. of
course Pinal rich Edson has the latest
tonight from the State Department there
appears to be little progress in trade
negotiations between the United States
Canada and Mexico just three days ahead
of a congressional deadline a source
close to the discussion says there are
no meetings scheduled this week between
US Trade Representative Robert light
Heiser the Canadian foreign affairs
minister and Mexican economy minister
the trio met throughout last week in an
attempt to try to secure an updated
version of the North American Free Trade
Agreement or NAFTA NAFTA has been a
horrible horrible disaster for this
country the Trump administration has
forced a renegotiation to keep the u.s.
in the continental free-trade agreement
negotiators say there are differences on
auto manufacturing the system for
settling future disagreements and a u.s.
proposal to include an expiration date
on any new version of NAFTA to pull any
deal through Congress House Speaker Paul
Ryan says he needs an agreement soon
we'll see if they can get this done by
May 17th and gets the paper to Congress
without it he says the issue would fall
to the next Congress one voters will
choose in November's elections despite
the Congressional calendar Mexican and
Canadian negotiators say they refuse to
sacrifice substance over pressure I'm a
little skeptical that he will because
there are many people in Congress who
really want this really want this to
stay in place there'll be a lot of
people are adversely affected but that's
still hanging over our head with speaker
Ryan's deadline approaching the White
House says President Trump spoke today
with Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau the White House says the
president underscored the importance of
quickly concluding these negotiations
Brett Richardson live at the State
Department rich thank you